all right uh so data munging with python
and let me show you we'll start with
the I'm sorry uh was somebody saying
something
Conrad uh no you're good sorry about
that all right okay um all right so yeah
so this basically started with me trying
to figure
out what is happening right I mean how
are so many new things coming up and uh
how can I get a Handler on this thing
right so I started basically building
this um as as kind of notes to self um
and it grew from there because uh lots
and lots of people then then came up to
me and started showing interest and that
was kind of cool right so um let me
start today's presentation really
quickly um that's P
Global and here we
go
right so
um no idea why this is not rise working
as rise well we'll just take it from
here so
um oh by the way for these images um I
uh right after I presented this in Pon
India I got uh di 3 got released and uh
I started playing with that and I just
went nuts um so so I apologize the
entire Workshop was now litered with
these images but um yeah what if we
found Greeks doing data munging with
Pythons right that would be a fresco um
anyways so um quite often we see that
that um
uh we have these variety of Technologies
just coming up and and uh
going what am I trying to
do and we getting overwhelmed with hey
these new things are coming up again and
again and how do we get a handle on that
right um so so this this Workshop is me
trying to answer that question first for
myself but hopefully for a lot of us uh
around here right um let me start
quickly with my introduction I have 20
plus years of experience everywhere um
and I consistently hear text changing so
fast it's hard to keep up and I'm sure
you hear that too right um so if if
you're looking for me after the
presentation uh you can find me on
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram whatever
whatever right I works at work at Barnes
& Noble and I'm very happy to report
that I'm very very lucky to have run
into a really good
team um the the idea of a good team is
that we treat each other as experts we
don't tell each other how to do our jobs
and we keep each other on our toes right
I have to learn if I have to manage that
team and the team has to learn if they
have to live with me so so it's a really
good symbiotic relationship and it's uh
I'm very lucky it doesn't happen quite
often um additionally I write plays and
Screen plays and and and uh work in
films on the side as well um and I got
to shoot and produce this movie about a
year ago right it was uh released here
in India um um to to quite a quite some
Fanfare right so um yeah so legit
Bollywood experience in addition to p
python um so yeah so let me run this
that's how you run a video in a TI uh J
notebook um so needless to say I really
really like films and hence I hope it
justifies my inclination towards using
the movie lens data
set um that and the fact that it's
really easy to understand right so let
me just show you quickly what the movie
data set looks like um uh typically we
will be using two data sets from here
one is the ml25 million data set and the
other if you scroll all the way down
you'll see the educational purposes data
set education and development and we'll
be using this latest small data set
right um
I will be using it locally so on my
local machine I have this already
downloaded
um
and yeah so this one as well um and
interestingly enough this when you unzip
this this is about 1 gigabyte of
everything right so um quickly let me
show you this bit um um basically we're
looking at movies their
ratings the links to these these uh
movies to IMDb and and other websites
and the tags that users have associated
with these movies right so just four
different entities not complex at all
the readme file explains how the data
set is laid out right so you can
download and explore this data set
yourself or
um uh just go along Ong with the
workshop and it should be fine um I
tried my best to put in the the
links to so if I go to the workshop let
me go to the pi p a global folder um to
put links to collab right these may be
slightly messy or may not be working for
some situations let me know um and we
can update this in real time but for the
most part at least till yesterday these
were working fine right so you should be
able to without wasting time on too much
time on setup be able to click on collab
uh for any of these and then follow
along um I am going to request Conrad
that you speak up if somebody's asking
any questions or raising hands or
whatever because I can't I I I can't see
um I'm working on a different window so
I may not be able to see what's going on
did that make sense is that okay okay uh
perfect uh so we also have Desmond with
us and we will be monitoring the chat
and also the Q&A uh so and and we will
show it on the screen and also verbally
notify you if there's any questions
perfect perfect um yes so the GitHub
link let me first shared the repo link
with everybody because I've been just
harping around but but uh did not share
that so let me do that
first there we
go and let me know if you can access the
getar weo should not be a big
[Music]
issue all
right
so so let's get back to that Tech
changes so fast but I'll I'll speak for
maybe five more minutes um and that will
give everybody a chance to download the
git repo or clone it or Fork it or
whatever you like right
so um and then we'll also look at the G
repo separately right um is the font
size enough or should I should I
increase it more let me increase it more
anyways
hopefully this
works I don't
know um all right
um okay so so in addition to the movie
um I I got to collaborate on a play
called The Little Prince I hope a lot of
you have heard about this play uh this
book um and one of my favorite books and
one thing one quote that I came across
in this book was if you want to build a
ship Don't drum up people to collect
wood don't assign them
tasks but rather teach them to long for
the endless immensity of the sea I'll
say that again teach them to long for
the endless immensity of the sea and
this tutorial is basically my attempt at
doing that right so when we look at
technology and we say oh there's pandas
and now there's arrow and now there's
yet another technology called vs that
has come out of meta um and how many do
we learn and how do we keep up that
statement becomes problematic because
it's overwhelming and we don't know how
to solve it but if you like the field of
data engineering if we like the data
itself and if you're curious about how
what that data has to
offer um everything else becomes like a
ship that you'll be sailing on the sea
so I try to divide everything into a c
question or a ship question and ship
questions take a a lower priority right
they can be sold right there's Google
there's Chad gbd there's Bard which is
surprisingly good now um and there's
tons of other things now helping us
right so there's spy data
um so so effectively the focus has to be
on the ca we have to learn to love the
sea right and the ship then becomes the
easy part so um so that's my motivation
for the for the workshop um the approach
we'll take is we'll start with just
plain python right and I'll spend a good
chunk of time working on python because
all I want to do is you know just
lay all the concepts clearly and that
should give us enough grounding to be
able to cover Panda spark and anything
else like really really quickly and you
will see yourself as we go through the
exercises that you're able to just kind
of handle it really easily right so so
we will focus and it's entertaining it's
not boring at promise right so um we'll
start simple and then build on top of it
to the point my expectation or my hope
is that at the end of these two hours
you will be able to tackle any of these
data engines or or upcoming ones on your
own right um so so we'll cover like I
said the core python Collections and
then we'll see how numpy does better
than Python and and where it does better
and then how pandas Builds on top of
numpy and then how spark comes into the
picture and why is there a dask if
there's already a spark and what does
poers do if time permits we have a lot
to do right so so quickly
um if if we run this Workshop properly
like with every single notebook and
everything it becomes like a five-day
event we only have two hours right so
we'll not be able to cover things like
Funk tools ER tools time series or
categorical data and things like that
right so there's there's a lot of
questions and and what I've done is I've
built hopefully enough in the workshop
that you can continue to grow uh with
this one right so please interact
there's uh discussions enabled on the
GitHub repo so you can go to the
discussions Tab and start asking
questions a really good thing about a
workshop like this is that um there
really are no dumb questions when we are
very new very fresh to some something we
bring our own perspective and we
actually ask surprisingly deep questions
so it's it's really really interesting
to capture all the questions and sort of
build a knowledge base that's really
practical and Community generator right
so so ask your questions in the
discussion um if I can't get to them in
the talk we will definitely touch upon
them um I will definitely answer all of
them uh here um there was somebody who
actually wrote a question as an
issue and uh yeah so we had to then then
I answered that here as well right so so
prefer discussions or whatever whatever
is easy inconvenient for you all right
here we go um so let me quickly first
give you a walk through of the GitHub
repo right um learn data monging for
every data engine I've created a
separate
folder and it's growing you can see that
data Fusion is already there Ray is
already there I'm not saying too many
updates in ballista though so maybe it's
just going to be arrow in data fusion
and there's tons of other data engines
so what I'll do is I'll keep adding as I
explore more and more and more right
there's sidebars which were basically
things that I ran into or questions that
I were was asked which were not exactly
related to data engineering but like
kind of General enement questions um for
example how do you put in that that open
and collab button and things like that
so I just made sure that even that is
available everywhere there's archived
which is just a trash miscellaneous
drawer um I should have removed this
this is an error um and then on the read
me page what I've done is in addition to
all the notebooks and everything I've
put in all the references that helped me
learn right so everything is
transparently available aable you can
say hey here's a good resource that I
want to use and you can submit a pull
request for that right
um this I My Hope Is that this is the
most updated reference that I have um uh
and and a lot of these would be kind of
really really old you can see some links
from like 2014 here um but these were
all super interesting and if if I can
urge you to do one course that's the
advanced database systems um session
from
c um but okay let's get back to the repo
um and all the work that we will have to
refer to is in the pi data Global right
so if you go here you can see the links
to the notebooks that we will be will'll
be running
today right um please post a message
please uh uh raise a voice if you want
me to slow down or if you've missed
something we'll we'll happily cover it
right so let's invert the pyramid really
quickly here's the six things that I
typically ask when I'm when I'm choosing
the right ship for my Voyage right my
focus is the C so for any ship that I
choose I ask whether it is going to have
lazy evaluation or E eager eval cation
right of Expressions whether it supports
only scalar operations or whether it it
can support vectorized
operations um how does it represent the
data in memory right rowwise and column
wise uh row-wise or column wise and
column wise is typically also used these
days it's called column nner right so we
see a lot of these Vector data bases
coming up that are that say column ner
so we'll see what that really means here
right how is it represented on disk on
disk you would have heard of things like
par and avo and things like that and and
why are they important and then what are
the task scheduling features available
what sort of optimization considerations
are there and how poly does the
ecosystem get right so for example in
spark you're looking at Java you're
looking at at Scala and you're looking
at python right in in Arrow you're
looking at rust and you're looking at
python
but so operationally when when you want
to push this to production how hard does
it get so that's those are the
considerations that I typically look for
um but my focus is always on the data
and what it's teaching me right so so
let's quickly look at the python thing
first right python does eager evaluation
as soon as it it it's given a command
hey create find find the average of the
following numbers it just executes it
right um it's really good it because the
results are like available now right but
for larger data sets we may want to
filter the data set first right what's
called the predicate push
down predicate push down right that's
the fundamental optimization technique
uh available in practically every data
engine every database right so so things
like that if you want to filter a part
of the data before running your exe
before running your compute um eager
evaluation doesn't let you do that
that's the problem the second thing with
python is that it its data
representation in memory is kind of
expensive when you think about just
structured tabular data right but it's
beautifully done it's it's because of
duct typing right you don't really have
to worry about types and type safety and
stuff like that if it quacks like ducks
if it walks like a duck it is a duck
right python figures it out for you so
the way this works is that that if you
look at a table that's got um all the
the headers right so the movie ID title
and geners then each of these are stored
in different
locations and that are not
contiguous right so the analogy that I
typically make is Imagine an apartment
complex right each of these is one of
the apartments right so what the
computer has to do what what the the
data processing uh engine has to do is
go to each apartment and fetch the value
um and then go to the next one and fetch
the value and these may not be right
next to each other right so this is
apartment three this is apartment seven
so so the time spent in seeking the next
value is significant R it grows uh as
your data volumes grow python is not
going to put it in contiguous uh
chunks these are Dynamic array arrays so
they provide a lot of flexibility a lot
of functionality and they're really
really fun to use but they don't handle
gigabytes of data right um so let's
switch to the python notebook and see
see uh what we have in store right so
we'll go here and so I have deliberately
kept the the fun tools iter tools and
practice questions empty for now I think
I I went nuts and like put images
everywhere but beyond that it's all
empty um because I wanted to keep my
focus on this
notebook all right um so again support
for Google collab when you open this in
collab I need you to uncom comment this
that's control and forward slash
uncommon this and run it okay ideally it
should download the data and set things
up for you just fine and please let me
know if that doesn't
happen all right um in fact if you run
into any kind of special fun uh problem
do put it up in a discussion um so I can
research it and document like a proper
generalized solution for it right um we
will use the small mov Lance data set
here and the first thing that I'll do is
is open it up and try to understand what
it looks like and and how it works right
I'm deliberately not opening it up in in
Excel or or any anywhere else because
let's only use Python like like we would
in a real world situation right um um or
let's challenge ourselves to use only
python so what I do is I'll start
running these cells and I would very
much appreciate it if if most of you can
run it along side and tell me if you're
seeing what I'm seeing as well and I'll
explain the code cell by cell as we move
along all right um so we're we're just
basically first setting up these Global
variables where's my data located and
I'm creating these variables which I
will use forever to refer to the movies
file or the links file or the ratings
file or the tags file right so like we
saw in the data folder there's the
latest small we're using the small data
set right it unzips to about three and a
half megabytes which is Trivial should
be able to work on your computer right
so they remember we had these four
files right and so what we're doing
effectively is we're just saying hey
where are these files located so let's
just let's just see what's inside a file
right so
this is the very old school you have a
text file show me the first n
lines right I can I can just
um there we go there's a bug in here so
this should be like
this right
um um and that is it right so if I run
this I should see the
first what whatever five files five
lines right um so when I run this I see
that my move my my movies file has a
movie ID a title and a
genre well it's genr because all the
genres are club together and I
absolutely love these things because
then this is like another interesting
problem for us to solve and we don't
have to like think about oh this is bad
data no this is
a lot of data actually gets created this
way so it's it's pretty interesting if
you want to do some analysis now the
around the genres how you will actually
unpack this
thing I can do a render lines and say 12
and I should actually see what
happened did I do something
wrong
oh
I should say n l equals
12 I'm nervous guys hide is a big deal
right um all right so we see 12 of these
and here's an interesting case the
American president so do you see how
there's like a fourth comma here so if I
was to unpack this um I'll have to
wrestle with this fourth comma somehow
so if I was to just read the Cs v um
yeah this this is going to be
interesting right
so so this I'm just explaining to
everybody what the file looks like um
but you should the first question we
should think about when we get some data
is hey are there headers or are there no
headers right
and it's not a good thing or a bad thing
but they have their own processes right
if there were no headers I will need a
guarantee that the First Column is
always movie ID the second one's always
title and the third one's always geners
if there are headers then from one file
to the next the the column order can
Shuffle let's say there's an
asynchronous process that's actually
collecting this data um imagine
processing log files or imagine
processing uh different kind of sources
um same kind of data from different
sources let's say this sales file from
three different banks or something like
that right so so if you have headers you
don't need guarantees for position if
you don't have headers you need a
guarantee for position so so that's kind
of the first thing we think about
um we can uh we can test this for other
files as well if you want right um let
me know if if you're facing any problems
here we see that for the links file we
have the movie ID which is the same as
the movie ID
here and then there's a there's an ID
here that will that allow you to
generate the URL for its
IMDb page or the tmdb page right um
similarly for tags we can see the movie
ID and the user ID and the tag that the
user gave along with the timestamp when
the tag was given timestamps are f right
date time always the most fun bit of any
kind of data analysis um and finally
this the ratings part we're expecting
the same thing right a user a movie what
rating the user gave when did the rating
appear right so we're looking at the
same thing right a user ID movie ID
rating and time stamp so when you think
about it that's it that's the entire
movie lens data set super easy to
understand um I'm going to switch back
to the air meet window see if there's
any questions right
now okay there's like
[Music]
huge Anna says your testing or debugging
skills yes please thank
you um yeah all right so so let's
actually get to something more useful
than just looking at the data right so
so so what I've done is I've tried to
articulate what we will do as
problems right you can just listen to me
but you have the repo you can try to
solve these problems
yourselves and then we can compare notes
and you can say hey there was a better
way of doing this right and yeah my
secret ambition is to actually learn
from this session more than I give right
so so help me do that um
so python by default provides these
three data tools um a very interesting
thing that happened very recently was
somebody said hey I need to prepare for
my interview and can you help me uh with
python and I the first question I asked
him was hey are there arrays in
Python and surprisingly the gentleman
didn't know and python doesn't have what
we traditionally know know as arrayed
right python has lists and topl and
dictionaries and they're
fantastic all right on top of these
python then builds a collections module
that provides additional features and
we'll see how interesting things can get
only just using Python and nothing else
right um so let's think about some of
the questions we'll ask our data right
um we did this raw file
extraction right but is there a way for
me to extract five titles from the start
of the movies file and five from the end
of the file just just so I can see that
okay here's it's it's got nothing that's
corrupt right it's it's I can basically
touch any part of the file and it
returns something
sensible right um the second how much
how many how big that's a quote from
litter prints um how much does it cost
for me to process this data how many
lines are there right how big is the
data right can we get the different
markers of size and cost for the data
that's really interesting
um there is a new well not new but
there's this this growing movement of
finops where we want to be able to say
hey what will it cost me to build a
certain model or to do X kind of
evaluations and so if we have these
markers up front available it becomes
really easy to calculate that um
Downstream especially for cloudlike
environments if nothing else it will
actually tell you the time cost of your
computations right um well can we do
some database style access this is pure
python remember we do not have an rdbms
with us so can we like do a select star
for movies where movie ID is
206 I don't know let's try um what's the
frequency of each reading that's a
really interesting question right how
many times was the rating one given in
in the entire data how many times was
the rating two given to a variety of
movies at variety of times by a variety
of users in the data so if the data has
a lot of fives we know that it's know
that it's skewed towards lenient ratings
if the data has a skew towards one we
know that it's really really harsh so
this will help us see where the needle's
going and evaluate how fair these
ratings are how um how unbiased we can
take these as when we're building let's
say a recommendation engine is there a
way for us to find out the average
rating on the movies based on its movie
uh that's a typo I have no idea
why
oh IE
space apparently I don't know how to use
a keyboard um I'm learning guys right um
okay and finally can we find out the
number of movies in each genre so
remember this this this really packed
field can we unpack this come on that's
an interesting problem right um how many
adventure movies are there how many
romance movies are there and so on right
seriously simple questions really
interesting ways to find this out let's
crack each one of them in turn right uh
before I begin again quick check on the
air meat
bit am I speaking in the void oh there's
people here all
right okay here we go um let's get to
the lists right so really simple stuff
okay
um there is this notion of list
comprehensions and if I'm um and these
are basic python uh Concepts um I hope
all of us are aware of these if these
are not clear to you let me know I'll
I'll explain these really quickly but
lists fundamentally are ordered
sequences of elements the word elements
is important it is not lists do not
insist that you have everything of the
same type within
it right duct typing right it python as
its traversing through the list can
figure out what type of element it is
right um and lists are mutable you can
actually change the values in a list
very easily um so so we're create a
movie titles
comprehension
um well spoiler alert we have a really
interesting section on list
comprehensions in this notebook and I'll
skip it I let let's have kind of a poll
if you want to get into nested list
comprehensions in this notebook it'll
add maybe five minutes to our to our
overall presentation um so let's look at
movie titles what we're basically saying
is that for each line
in the file that I
open right I want you to split that line
using a comma and just pick up the
second field so we have zerob based
arrays pick up the second field
seriously simple code can anybody tell
me why there's a one
here I'll switch to the
chat somebody tell me why there's a one
here
here yes thank
you awesome so yes because we want to
ignore the first line we saw where we
have the column headers that makes no
sense right we're looking for this line
that's the data so so like I said our
files have headers and this would have
been a really Minor Detail really easy
to miss and you know all hell would have
broken loose when you shipped the scope
to production right so let's run this
and what we see is that the first five
movies
here um I really like the style that
python provides um so we're saying from
the start of the the list till the fifth
record till the index is at number five
you give me that and the minus says from
the last count five and give me all of
them right and this this missing thing
is well it's the last one right so so
look at what we just
did we basically could read any part of
this right so I can just
say print and let me add a new line so
there's some
space dot join and I can say movie
titles and give me two
numbers 200 to
207 right pretty
cool so I can access any random part of
this I really
should
say
random
did I see do you see random a
somewhere man I should have woron my
glasses oh there we
[Music]
go so yeah we can actually pick movies
from any any part of the file so looks
like we have a good file um yeah so
quick quick quick poll do you want to
get into nested list comprehensions
[Music]
um you know what I will skip this for
now right um and if you say if enough
people say we want to talk about nested
list comprehensions will come back here
right I just want to show you one line
here that's that's really precious
that's amazing to read and this is genre
for
genre in genre SP genre in genre come on
this is
precious this code if you put I promise
you the next engineer who reads it is
gonna curse you it's gonna hate you so
much right so list comprehensions do
make me feel really dumb sometimes so
they're they're kind of cool but they
have they have a people problem um all
right how much how many how big
um let's look at all the methods
available for movie titles remember we
just created a list called the movie
titles right so let's look at all the
movie title methods
available and look at the methods
available for each element of that so
lists don't need to have all the all the
elements of the same type but but in our
case we know that all the elements are
of the same type right so so let's look
at both and then also see the type of
that element so I'm going to run
this and now if you print
this this is very interesting so look at
look at the 48 methods that each list
supports right each time you create a
list right that movie titles internally
has 48 instances
um 48 method instances right so you can
add to it it defines the
class it gives you a way to check the
contains it gives you a way to to um to
assess equality greater than less than
hash and so on and so forth um and it
does give additional functions like you
can append to the list you can extend to
the list it's very interesting the
difference between append and extend
hopefully we cover that in this notebook
um but you can see that all these
features are available out of the box
for a list um this is very similar to
the array interface that we see in
JavaScript many of times right um so
really interesting for me to see this
available uh try doing that in Java
without creating an iterator class right
so so yeah this is quite quite awesome
but here's the kicker for each element
in the list we have similarly so many
methods because you know it can be any
type so duct typing means we have to
support a general purpose functionality
right so every record in the movies data
file has 81
methods and 48 methods for the overall
list right so that's interesting right
um so spoiler alert that's one of the
optimizations that numpy will build upon
so the insight there was that if you're
doing a general purpose data analysis um
we can actually restrict the duct typing
thing right so we can say oh we only
need strings in this column or we only
need integers in this column and we can
start paying attention to data types and
maybe that gives us some optimization
and we'll see what kind of optimization
there is right
so so what we'll do is before we tackle
uh other kinds of uh other kinds of uh
um data structures let's quickly build a
helper method I'm not going to go
through the code here it's really really
simple we're still getting the same um
um dir for all the methods and size and
so on and so forth right so really
simple stuff and here's testing this
method so if I create a uh integer it
has 73 methods if I create a float it
has 59 methods if I create a string we
just created one 81 methods and so on so
so kind of works right um I wonder if
there's a way to create a general
purpose message that also uh general
purpose uh um function that also handles
things like pandas data frames and and
Spark data frames and so on um but for
now like this is good enough right um so
now let's let's get back to the
regularly scheduled programming that's
kind of an old timey radio thing I don't
know if anybody I was there have been
people who asked me what does that mean
actually why do you say that so I'm old
um so tuples right
um um same kind of thing except that
these are pairs of information that go
together right so you can now start
thinking about tables in rdbms where you
can say or like things like coordinates
uh uh in in computer Graphics right so
so you can basically start binding
information together and they travel
together right so I want to say hey what
are all the movies and just the genre
pairs I don't really care about the
movie IDs or anything else just help me
create these ones right so again we're
doing the same thing we're we're using
list
comprehensions and this is a list list
of
tles right so tles are indicated with
the brackets right and we're saying
create a topple where the first value is
the movie title and the second value is
the list of the genes right and that's
it it's kind of the same code one means
headers are there right so we suddenly
have a way of looking add two things
together and that's added information
but you see this this r and
in um I'm looking for suggestions from
from Folks at the call how to remove
that we're going to remove that in in in
in a future uh event but right now
here's an interesting exercise uh right
now how many of us can actually remove
this part um and then when we look at
the the overhead from the the the tles
like we saw 48 methods for that
class so
many uh um records covering so many
levels of depth occupying so much
memory in the system remember the movies
file by default is just about 483
kilobytes right so so 4 kilobytes blooms
to
two um let me interject there's a
question for you sure yeah that's type
annotation feature can can be used to
limit the performance implications due
to Python's Dynamic language feature or
are there other ways to do
this I apologize do you mind saying that
again I I didn't hear that sorry so it's
the chat chat
session that's that's type annotation no
scroll down a little
bit Y type
annotations can be used to limit the
performance implications oh yes so so
yes and no depends upon the kind of
operations we're trying to perform right
and we'll cover that so we'll not
specifically cover type annotations but
we'll cover so the typing module itself
um I want to handle separately um in a
different notebook uh but we will cover
how to tackle this overhead here um so
stay tuned um but great question by the
way um so so so again we saw the
overhead and we're looking at something
that blooms into 2 megabytes
almost um just and we actually shaved
information away we actually rejected
one of the columns and the data that was
available to us and still it's covering
this much so that's kind of the overhead
we're looking at I I know that I'm
making it sound like it's a really bad
thing to have this overhead it's fun
it's amazing when we're doing
application programming or when we're
doing like some quick and dirty stuff
but it becomes a problem when we're
handling handling larger volumes of data
um the same thing uh I've I've covered
for the individual parts of the tuples
right so each Tuple uh covers 35 methods
it's got two a length of two because
it's got the movie title and the genres
right and it covers three levels of
depth anybody tell me what these three
levels
are a tle has two things so what's the
third
level come on this is really
easy let me know uh it's the tupple
itself so the data structure itself and
the things inside it right
um and this is the individual elements
and those are strings right so we know
that's 81 method so imagine when all of
this gets nested you end up with 29,000
thousand methods available in your
memory doing nothing at all why because
eager evaluation we just evaluated
everything so python just filled up the
memory so eager evaluation is a is a is
a interesting Beast it helps you keep
everything ready now but it also limits
how much you can scale right um and
let's look at dictionaries really
quickly I want to just just move on from
here um the same thing happening here we
we're we just created a dictionary let
me just show you quickly
um where did I
go let me do this actually because it's
a better idea dictionaries all right um
so what we're doing here is that we're
splitting the data with the comma and
we're saying movie ID and title and that
should give you a hint to what's going
to happen right I'm going to create a
key in the dictionary that's the movie
ID and assign at the
title right so same I can list the first
five I can list the last five works just
fine but this is the first one right we
can now access just like an rdbms we can
say what's movie ID
260 right and that's well Star Wars
hopefully some of us have seen that
movie it's like an art film from from
back back in the day um and we have N9
9,742 movies in our data set and here's
the overhead right we're looking at
about 1,300 1,400 kilobytes in the
memory
um again we actually
removed the genr column which is
probably the largest column there is and
we still ended up with 1,398 KB right um
and then finally there's sets sets are
interesting sets actually evaluate
uniqueness each time you add something
into them sets just like the
mathematical concept don't allow for
duplicates that's awesome because
because now I can just push stuff into
sets and say I'm I know everything's
unique inside right so so what I'm doing
here is trying to load all all the move
all the genres I'm sorry right I'm
trying to identify what are all the
genres in my data set because remember
if we go back
up oh my God I'm G have to scroll again
um can you see how romance happens
multiple times comedy happens multiple
times so if I just let the genres
be I'll not get the unique uh sense
so what I'm doing here is is uh trying
to print all the unique genres and this
is where our extra comma plays truant
because we now have these parts of the
movie title actually appearing as genres
that's a problem right so reading CSV
data is a very interesting problem in
itself uh which we'll cover in a
separate notebook because I want to
cover building a parser for raw python
for Apache spark for dask separately
right so we'll build a separate notebook
around there but for
now um let's just try again okay what
I'm going to do is I'm going to call
strip and
split right and I'm going to now look at
the
last last
uh
entry in my row data and say Split That
by a
pipe right so it doesn't matter if my
line has four entries or three because
of the comma extra comma I just pick up
the last
one and effectively that gets us all the
genres in each record and we just keep
pushing that into the set and well
immediately we get we get all the unique
genres so simple so if you had this bit
which is all the genres with the
duplicates right once you've once you've
had this it's trivial to turn it into a
set except there's processing cost
associated with it so we'll look at it
right so the moment I do that
that's so that's the the the unique
geners uh that we find right so here we
have all the geners that is there in the
data interestingly I think there's no
genres listed as well that's that's
pretty cool some films don't have a
genre pretty awesome right um so there's
there's inherently some null values
available in the genre data which means
we'll have to be careful if we're trying
to um if we're trying to create cohorts
or buckets it's based on joners um let's
look at the O overheads right
um yeah not
bad but let's think about uh and I think
I'm doing that somewhere down the the
the I don't know where I did it but um
later in the in the notebook we'll
actually calculate the
cost for uh um for these right so am I
doing that here itself oh yeah there we
go so so to calculate the cost um what
does a uniqueness check take it will
have to parse the list once right for
one uniqueness the second one pars it
again third one pars it again and so on
so worst case scenario we have a big old
N squared complexity here right in our
specific case if if we just wanted to
calculate the number of operations it
will be the number of genre a number of
elements and genres with duplicates list
and the number of total unique genres
found right so
that's oh my God that's like four
441,000
operations yeah that that can be
expensive right so so yeah sets are
really cool they're they're kind of
expensive but if you were to write that
code yourself you know and everybody has
to write a distinct right everybody has
written an SQL statement with distinct
right so so yeah they're expensive and
we have a measure of how expensive they
are but they're really interesting and
thank God they're available out of the
box um so let's look at some of the uh
features available in the collections
module and then quickly move on to the
numai uh notebook so sorry before before
you go ahead there's another question
um the last chap
yes yes this is thank you I I'm sorry I
I don't know how to pronounce your name
ad thank you for the question I'm
covering that in a few minutes right
[Music]
um right so let's look at the named tle
name tle is basically just expressing
the schema or the equivalent of a schema
um of course being python there's more
than one ways of expressing a schema um
but name t is one of the simplest one
right so we can say hey my movie is a
named tupple my movie class is named tle
and it's got three columns it's got a
genre a title and a rating
right um and I can just create a
variable put put a movie in it and I
should be able to access these indiv
idual values using the dot notation
right so so you can just you can see
that I'm taking that variable and just
saying dot title so I can just literally
create values here and again oh did I
not thank god um
so all I'm doing is inputting values and
you can see duct typing happening here
because we have strings and we have a
float right so we didn't actually
Express hey my rating is a float it it
picks it on its own um similarly I can
say here's a name tle for rating and
like we discovered before it's got a
user it's got a movie the rating the
user gave to the movie and when the
rating was given right um and very
simply I can actually create all the
ratings as a name tle from the ratings
file
and now I can just play with the ratings
[Music]
um I don't I I've not tested if rating
is coming in as a string or not my
intuition says rating is a string in
this case I'm going have to convert it
ourselves um so the interesting bit here
is the
star
right so what this line is going to do
is it's going to generate one or more
arguments that will go into the rating
function right which will generate a
named tble for us right so the star
basically says one or more positional
arguments the double star says keyword
arguments right and you can just pass
this as an array um a lot of people I
meet have been forever confused with it
so I just put a link here not that hard
just look at it right so and I can now
randomly check ratings for individual
movies there we go and now I can look at
the overheads um and we're looking at
about six megabytes in the
memory that's uh that's uh and if you
look at how complex name tles are as
compared to plain old old lists because
when you think about it just a list
right um um where did I go
there we go so if I just run that we're
looking at you know it's approximately
five times in our case makes sense right
four extra Fields um
so yeah more expensive but certainly
convenient now I don't know how to
pronounce that I pronounce a DQ because
that makes sense to me double ended q
but a lot of people I know pronounce it
like a
like deck so please comment and say how
you pronounce it it's like a gif GIF uh
thing that I keep running into I'll say
DQ at least for this presentation right
um from collections we again import um
and we basically build a DQ where it's
it's in the name right it's a double
ended que and and you when you look at
the implementation it's super simple
we're adding adding adding elements and
we're saying it cannot have more than
five elements so the Q starts popping
individual elements off as it keeps
adding elements on the
right super simple right um overheads
I'll just run it I don't think it's
important right now counter is very
interesting counter is effectively the
dot count aggregator that we find in
multiple places right so as available
how the Box in a language that's just
I've I've not seen that in JavaScript
I've not seen that in Java I've not seen
that in C++ certainly um so this is kind
of interesting that a language just says
hey I'll I'll give you batteries in
included um all right um same we have an
arbitrary list of genres I'm going to
say hey
count uh uh each of these occurences
right so this is kind of a grou by.
count happening right and remember how
we created the genres with duplicates
right at the Top If I just give it to a
counter it's going to tell me how many
drama movies we have how many comedy
movies we have how many Thrillers and
that was one of the questions we were
trying to answer at the top right so so
did any of you get here before I did
because I'm wasting too much
time okay um also did the
oh I have not covered the name tles
versus dictionaries just yet right
um so let's let's now talk about a
slightly more complex idea count the
frequency of each
rating it's not hard remember we've
actually done all of this right so let's
just try it once so name tle counter
let's import them again um we're saying
hey rating is a name tupple we've
defined it up stairs as well let's just
do it again remember the asterisk here
it just says positional arguments one or
more found um and that's it and we're
doing the one because we're skipping the
header right
um and that's it we we have a list of
ratings I love dictionary comprehension
sorry list comprehensions oh my God look
at the precious line of code here I I
don't know
you can you can actually kind of like
put this on a T-shirt and say read it if
you dare right um Don K um I'm I'm a I
like that gentleman a lot he came up
with this idea of literate programming
where you can just read code as if you
were reading a novel right and I think
uh all the discussions around
objectoriented or functional they
actually distract us from their literate
programming thing and the pure python is
is closest we've gotten there uh at at
scale but again we have list
comprehension so yeah limitations to
everything um but yeah there we go we
suddenly have a list of uh uh ratings
and we know that four there's
26,800 movies that have a 4.0 rating
5,500 movies that's about five in the
rating and there's there's so many
movies would that have actually have a
two
0.5 I'd love to dig deeper into this
one um and so we can now see the most
common ratings we can see uh the the the
the least common ones and so on right
super easy again kind of overheads is a
theme on this notebook right so let's
just keep looking at it that number blew
my mind
and just to calculate that ratings we
had
like 28
megabytes what and the ratings file
itself is like two megabytes two and a
half
megabytes so yeah interesting um finally
we have the order dict order dict
dictionaries by default do not guarantee
the order of their keys they're used
they use hashes right so just they're
all um um all the keys are basically
hashed inside a dictionary so you can
guarantee order order dict does which
obviously means it's slower than a
regular
dictionary um so we're we're adding
movies u in an order dict in order and
you will be able to get them out in the
same order right so fairly simple what
is the average rating of a movie in the
rating file average rating so let's say
we look at Inception what is the average
rating of
inception now you think about it it's
the the aut dict really works here right
so again we pick up the ratings that we
had calculated above and uh we just have
to put it in an ordered di where the key
is the movie
ID right and each time we find a new
rating we just push it into a
list right and for that list we can just
sum them and and uh divide them by the
number of movies right so there we go
and now I can basically calculate the
average rating for I have the average
rating for any movie you like so you
give me the movie ID let's say 260 and I
have the rating for Star Wars come on
we're doing rdbms stuff out of plain
python that's awesome right and all
we're going to look at is even for any
data engine these kind of data
structures we're not looking for
anything special we're we're going to
just see hey you're spark how do
dictionaries work inside you how do
utter dicks work inside you how does a
counter work and things like that right
so we're basically covered now that
we've understood this part everything
else is easy and you'll see in a
minute
um so so default dig basically inserts
an a default value where there's a null
I'm not going to uh waste too much time
there and this is the last one right
we're going to
count um the the the number of movies by
genre one more time right so we're using
the default dict in this case um so even
if there's no genre available on certain
lines we get it so like I said about
calculating the same thing in Python you
can be done in multiple ways
you can have a more interesting way of
doing it than I had and so I'm really
looking forward to those uh bits um but
let's get back to our presentation right
this was fun this was quick
um so what did we see the first big
thing we
saw was eager evaluation python
evaluates everything as soon as it finds
it right that means I don't get the
opportunity to optimize first I just get
the answer right so as my data sets
increase I want to be able to First say
I'm only looking for all the movies
released in
1995 I'm not looking for everything so I
want to be able to filter my set down
before I do evaluations on it but right
now with eager everything's gonna happen
right so um then python represents
two-dimensional data rowwise right all
the all the data structures we saw
whatever you consider a record will
actually exist together and then the
next record and then the next record and
so on right they are not
contiguous right so just the apartment
complex analogy every value lives in a
different house and whoever's getting
all the values will have to go to
different different houses and we'll
have to travel record by record so if I
say get me row number five it will have
to Traverse through row number one two 3
4 five and then get it right so slightly
slow but it's Dynamic and it supports
duct typing so it's awesome right um we
saw that there's like 48 methods each
list supports overhead so so like we had
that spoiler alert numpy improves upon
that right so what does numpy
do I'm going to quickly check for
questions before I move on
oh they
are thank you morit I actually didn't
rely on that dictionary so much but
thank you
um thank you Jose um all right let's
move on so numai uses uniform data types
so that python overhead we had for duct
typing goes away this speeds things up
all right so um and the second thing
numai does at the cost of memory usage
is to keep everything together so numai
will not say my my my movie title lives
in one apartment and JRE lives in
another apartment somewhere else no Jer
lives right next to the title right and
they know so numai has two things it
knows how big a movie title is movie ID
movie title and genre and it knows
exactly where they are so it doesn't
have to waste time looking for that
value right so can you see the
difference between the two uh here I've
tried to color code The Columns as well
so it's slightly easier um but I know
that it's like a really dense diagram um
you can look at it at leisure put up
something in the in the discussions if
I'm not able to answer your questions
right now um
well yeah I'll look forward to your
comments um all right so so this is
interesting right because now I can do a
lot of things numai saying as long as
you care about your data types and don't
make me care for your data types I can
give you speed and I can give you scale
napai also does one more thing which is
really really old programmers here I
know at least one who I hope is in the
session um will know the the way data is
represented in memory can be two
different ways it can be the row
oriented data or column oriented data
right and in this case what numai is
helping us do is say hey do you want me
to put things in c order or Fortran
order Fortran order Fortran order is
basically all the values of all the
columns together then the next column
and the next column and I really like
this this was how Fortran would create
the arrays and this is what we call
columnar databases today they basically
store all the values of the column
together um if you're looking at par
each file is basically one column right
if you're looking at Apache arrow in the
memory it's going to say all the values
of column one live together all the
values of column two live together all
the values of column three live together
and that's it
right so this this is fun because now
what we can do is we can actually use
fewer columns and not pay for shaving
the extra data off right we can just say
I just need my movie IDs and I just need
my genres and I don't need the titles
and that's it it will not waste time
getting me the titles did that make
sense so there's a typical interview
question find the max salary from
employee table so I just put it here in
this case it's easier because an
employee table may have the employee
name age address blood type and then the
salary designation as well um and you
only need the ID and the salary col so
you're not paying for all the extra data
you don't have to load it you don't have
to read it right so this is really fast
and memory efficient um Apache Arrow um
is a a very new format well not new it's
been it's been in the works for ages now
um but very
interesting uh format that enables not
only column oriented representation in
memory but also allows interoperability
so you can have some data monging done
in Python and then pass it to spark I'm
sorry in pandas and then pass it to
spark and then pass it to data Fusion in
Rust and the data Remains the Same at at
no added cost so you don't have to like
serialize der serialize serialize
deserialize it's really really really
well done um so let's switch to the
numpy notebook really quickly I will
close this
one and open the numpy
one all right um this is The Notebook
right not the zero one the zero one's
just empty um here we go some extra
buildings more machinery numpy's cooking
right um so let's really quickly again
open in collab you can just use this bit
um I'll just run these things for setup
purposes I'm using version one
1262 um let's look at how numpy is
faster than python lists you know how
fast is dpai I don't know so what I did
was I just took a really big number 10
million um and then I created a python
list so list has 0 to 10 million minus
one one in one list right so that's a
list of 10 million numbers and I'm going
just going to say how long does it take
for me to sum that
list and then in a numpy array how much
does it take for numpy to Summit that's
really simple right when I run it I can
see that right now on my machine numpy
is 22 times faster that's awesome
because as my data grows I can do 22
times more processing in the same amount
of time right so it's kind of kind of
cool here's another test right I'm going
to take two lists this time and sum them
right let's try this
again it's a more complex operation and
it actually is
faster why is that happening because
we're basically able to say we're
basically able to multiply the gains
that we get
um when we consider the the type safety
that mumai is saying and the the
contiguous data blocks in your memory
right so again typ casting rules are
important in
numai if I give it an array of different
data types how does numpy determine the
data type right so so um there's a bunch
of test T that I have put in um and
you'll see that it just keeps saying
Unicode uh string less than 11
characters is the first
one and
uh that this one's of course an
exception um and the third one is
integer 64 right so here I specified the
data type here I specified the data type
but gave it the incorrect data and here
I I did not specify the data typee so
it's going to take the least widest data
type to cover all the elements in the
array low the
smallest thing that covers all the
elements I don't know if that makes
sense but like it it
will so
um let's look at the memory overhead
right because we have strict data types
let's see uh what the memory overhead is
right so here's a really simple method
what I'm doing is I'm just picking up
the number of bytes that uh numpy arrays
consuming versus I'm using get size off
here to say here's the bytes consumed in
the memory right and that I'm converting
it into kilobytes for easier reading and
so when we run this here we go so that's
kind of halfish right 50% less memory
that's awesome that's like for nothing
we just said you know import numpy as NP
and then used numpy array and we get 50%
of our memory back that's pretty cool um
so so we talked about the contiguous um
um sets right so we talked about the
contiguous addressing of data we numpy
by default goes row oriented as well you
have to expressly convert it into
columns we'll do it at the end of this
note but I'm I'm trying to avoid that
right we'll cover that in a different
session if if we mean again
um so let's quickly look
at the memory addressing right um
hopefully this will make sense if it
doesn't we'll just quickly move on and
pretend it never happened right um so
what I've done is I've created an uh an
array here each number is taking 32
bytes right um and numai basically says
Hey from apartment one to apartment two
because now they're equally sized um
each step that I have to take is called
a
stride all right so what I'm trying to
do is uh say how big is each stride and
that's that's got to
be 16 in this case right um so when
think about it so later what I did was I
created a me I created an array that
array and walked through each element
and I said well give me the memory
address how do you find that memory
address you basically look at the array
interface it's a private interface
inside the array right and you can
actually look at the data part here um
and in fact uh if you have the notebook
you can I welcome you to to investigate
this data structure more it's really
really interesting so so um so when I
look at the memory addresses the python
ones are all over the place right there
like 52 84 we don't know but this one is
the same address all the time why
because it's just going to say 84 plus
16 here plus 16 here plus 16 here plus
16 so it's just doing that so you're
you're checking out the 100th element
means the Base address plus 100 into 16
it's actually not a walk here it says go
to this element this guy's going to
point you to the next one go to the next
one this gu's going to point you to the
next one and so on so this one is really
really really efficient the cost is that
we have to take care of our data types
make sense so let's do some problems
with numpy and I'm like kind of
interested in in in how we can leverage
numpy to look at our C right so again
how many movies were released each year
how many movies were released in '94 in
'95 in '96 and a very common problem is
that there's no group buy available in
numpy um so before we get into it I just
want to check if there's
questions
um anything else I should be attending
to no let's look at number five so
here's what I did right again we've done
this before I say where my data is
located what those files are the
idiosyncrasies of my data set remember
there was the American president that
has a comma in it now when I have to
load this file into numpy I will have to
attend to it because the ear is embedded
in the title so what I'll have to do is
I'll have to create a list of titles
extract the ear from it and then do some
sort of
groupy right that's the first problem
the second problem on average how many
movies were released per year so if
let's say there were 200 movies released
in 95 700 in 96 three in 97 I'm just
making arbitrary numbers on average
across the entire data set how many
movies did we get every year did we get
like 50 movies a year on average what
was that average right um so the second
one's simple if the first one is done
right I hope can see that um so of
course we'll use regular Expressions um
I tried using this but I just kept it
aside there's a very very very cool
thing that regexes do which is called a
look around and uh this one is called a
positive look ahead right it's going to
say identify the comma for me that is
followed by a double quote Mark right um
so in this case this one right um
so I don't think we'll need it so let's
just create a regular expression for the
ear so it's going to say hey there's a
parenthesis between the
parentheses there's there's got to be
four digits and if you match this
pattern pick it up right so same as
before we're just going line by line and
we're dumping everything that we read
into this St
um list literally a
list so no numpy stuff yet
right and you can see that I created a
movie ID I did a title in title I'm
actually joining really interestingly um
um actually if you can figure this
algorithm out I I promise you you'll be
it's so much fun um it just basically
just circumnavigates the whole comma
problem completely
um and then I do the regular expression
match to extract the ear right here
itself and then the last part is the
genres right so I just take it up and I
say here's my list each element in my
list is a list again which is a movie ID
title ear in genes right and then I
basically say hey it's an
Umpire and when I try to print the
shapes let me just run this and then try
to run this one it says you have 9742
movies each one of them having four
Fields super interesting now I have so
if I want to print head right numai
doesn't have a head um but we can use
the same python list format to say uh it
should have been the um so just give me
the the first five or the first 10 or
whatever right uh do you want to do 12
let's do 12 let's see if the American
president go
through o we got
it and we got the year as
well and so now I Define a general
purpose Group by we did this in the last
notebook it shouldn't be hard we did
this with dictionaries right so each
time I find a new
movie I'm going to create a new key in
the dictionary and each time I
encounter uh in this case I'm creating a
a year right so each time I find a new
year I'm going to uh create a new key
and the value will be a list with all
the all the all the elements uh that are
basically belong that belong to that key
right um so super easy I do that and
then I build a count function on top of
it where I say first build me all the
groups and then for each group just get
me the length of each group that's my
count right so a count is super easy to
do two literally whatever like half a
dozen lines of code and here we
go I can now tell you we have a proper
group Buy in numpy and pure python a
group by from scratch that's exactly
what a database does that's exactly what
any data engine will do You Now
understand how a group bu Works
fundamentally so when you're evaluating
group bu structures and pandas in in the
next notebook it's not going to be that
hard and we don't care about the syntax
because that's a ship question we don't
really care about it the C is our main
concern right so we can just look at the
count for
everything uh there's a movie from
1908 okay no not bad um um of course
there were more than one movies released
in 1908 but our data set only has one um
so let's look at all the ears this this
uh syntax just says give me all the uh
elements in your numpy array but only
give the zeroth column like the First
Column right so I do that I see all the
years right there's actually a none as
well and then
I say the count and that's exactly the
same corresponding count so I can
actually see um I have the count for
every single movie release every single
year in my data set and here's the
average about 91 movies every year not
bad um I'm not going to cover the Row
versus cumar I've tried to play with it
and convert the row major order to
column major order and so on in memory
um it gets super confusing really really
fast so let's skip this part and move on
to
pandas right so going back to our
presentation um let's just quickly
summarize significantly fact or
vectorized execution did you understand
what vectorized was vectorized is we
don't have to write for Loops right it
applies to the entire list all at the
same time uh homogeneous data types one
column one type period right lowlevel
implementation in C so these are
basically C like arrays so anybody who's
programmed in C will know that that's
how you count up an array in C right
with a stride and a base address and so
on um and then there's tons of helper
functions for maths and numbers that we
didn't touch but you know but there's no
Group by there is no join so what do we
do for regular data wrangling needs
we're going to have to Implement them
from scratch but the pandas folks said
well there was once a package called
plier in r that had the split apply
combine approach let's build that in in
P in Python and use numpy as our data
engine right so every column in a pandas
data frame is effectively a numi array
and then pandas builds the the the group
by and all that fun stuff for you right
um the next version of pandas supports
Apache Arrow as a backend so instead of
using numpy you can start using Apache
Arrow right um I don't want to cover
Apache arrow in this Workshop primarily
because it's like a half an hour
discussion on its own and I want to show
some code around that but in the
workshop in the in the repo I will be
building a separate Arrow related uh
section um so there's a curiosity note I
wrote here let's let's read it later
right um let's switch to the pandas
notebook at this point so I'm going to
go pandas quick quick quick we have to
cover spark at least um so we'll do the
basic stuff in pandas and then move on
to spark because um there's interesting
questions in spark that I think you'll
enjoy um same as before uh let's locate
the data let's specify the file names
import Pai and pandas I'm using these
versions hopefully your versions match
and then we do this
CSV uh dialect so now with pandas we're
going to get a Helper function that
reads our CSV for us instead of building
all those tricks that we built to
address the commas and so on uh we're
going to need this right so so let's try
loading movies with this one and if you
were to do just a PD panda do. read CSV
it's going to
break
because the the name they have given in
this particular case is quote car quote
character right
so really really old progam like
programmers like me um we used to just
use the Escape character but CSV
dialects have become complex enough
thank you to Microsoft Excel um that we
we now have these two definitions and so
the method signature that Panda's read
CSV method requires is a quote character
right in in our case it's the same thing
it's the double quote right the the read
me file says it's escaped using double
groups but in reality it's quoted using
double groups right so that small uh
semantic difference ends up crashing
your code and giving you head headache
for hours and hours just you
know um you don't have to lose hair like
I do um this is remember your code card
um and that's it so when we when we
basically run this stuff uh we can
actually do a a we can actually really
quickly look at it and we got the
American president correct this time not
that hard in fact like a single line of
code wow right so so I really appreciate
pandas and what it brings to the table
especially when you think about that
Underneath It All it's an entire numpy
column so I can do really advanced math
and just be in
pandas so here's the data types for the
column um I'm going to just load the
other ones as well really quickly they
shouldn't be a problem they shouldn't be
hard um I'm interested a little bit in
the ratings one so here's how I do date
time stamps right I just import that as
regular integers and then convert them
after the fact I don't know why maybe
it's my luck it almost always break
breaks when I Supply a date time
directly into the schema right so let's
do that I have supplied a
schema uh here and then I have set up my
quote car and everything else and I'm
going to load the file loads this is an
integer right now now I'm going to
convert it using the two date time
method and I'm going to just run that
here we go now I have a proper date
time and I can now start extracting the
actual date time for my ratings instead
of the Unix timestamp that we had before
make
sense so I just created a new column and
it's again it's literally like a python
list
so you can just keep adding new keys as
new columns super simple as of now did
is there anybody who thinks this is
really complicated code that we could
not make sense
of oh did everybody leave oh no there's
people here I see because I can see you
guys I feel like oh everybody's left and
I'm talking into the
word well thank you so much uh all right
so
so this is super simple code right um
let's try one more time and playing with
the datetime just just so we remember
this one all
right um this time we're going to create
three columns say date month and year
and we're just doing the same thing it's
literally the
same operation and we now can Group by
the the the month we can say how many
movies released in
September or how many ratings I'm sorry
in this case were given in the month of
September across all the years not bad
or are there more ratings given on the
first of the month or on the last day of
the month right so we can start thinking
about time series we're not covering
time series which is a shame but we can
start looking at time series earnestly
with this data um that's it I think uh
tag is the same thing I'm just going to
run the notebook see if anything breaks
and then quickly move on to actual data
mju right
um yeah just this is the Zen of python I
kind of like it um but let's let's move
on to the second Panda's notebook
surprisingly the Panda's notebook took
us like five
minutes once the the once we knew what
the C looked
like yeah this was easy um same same
thing as before we're running running
running running everything and then
import numbers here's the the let me
just load the movie Set and then ask
questions right so we have the movies in
place and the ratings in
place come on
datetime right now let's do the problems
right find out how many movies have
commas in them how many movie titles
have commas in them
can we again extract the year of the
release we've done this before and you
know it's easy right and put it in a
separate column how many movies in the
data set from each year we've done this
before super easy can we calculate an
average rating again come on how many
times was each movie rated the rating
frequency is there a way I can query the
movie ID and get its title so we're
doing kind of the same things but in
pandas this time let's see how easy it
is
right so here's my
movies and I can just say movie
title do string. contains a comma and
you give me a head of that one right so
I have uh I have a mask I have a a a
data frame that's as large as the
previous one except if it doesn't
contain a comma it says false where it
contains a comma it says true I can
filter that
and just say how many TRS right so here
I go we we we can just do a DOT contains
equal equal true that's a filter and
that we get all the movies that have
only commas in them that's a simple
count right so suddenly my code is so
much more
readable that's the thing that Panda's
brought to the table it took up
everything python gives everything numpy
gives and and gave it
conveniently right
um you're release how hard can this one
be right
so so the loc is interesting right so
pandas what it does is it adds an extra
data structure to your data which it
calls the index the index is basically a
numpy array but it's not mutable you
can't change it and it's it guarantees
uniqueness so you can't have two
duplicate values or or you can have you
cannot have duplicate values in an index
we have 10 minutes I'll touch the first
Spark and then we'll go to questions
right um and the same like you you would
have guessed it right we just run a
regex pattern extract the year we've
done this before super easy we just
running a string method here right and
that's it and now we have a ear in a
separate column so what took us maybe
six lines of code before takes us one
layer gr right and now I can actually do
the same thing I can actually uh group
it by ear so instead of writing a group
by Method my own pandas provides me a
group by object this is a group by
object and it will have its own set of
uh methods so let me just do that let me
just first create a group bu and before
I execute this let me just show you uh
that the group bu method itself has tons
of features available in it right and
when you think about it Group by must
support some sort of duct typing right
because you can gr bu on any kind of
value so so you can have all these uh
aggregation functions built into the
group bu right and just play around once
you have a group bu object just keep
playing around with it right so um with
the group buy I can look at all the
groups and all the keys do you remember
the groups and keys we created a
dictionary and we created a keys in
those dictionary that's a group by
object right
um you see that it's a it's a dictionary
inside um how many unique years in the
movies we know this
answer come on it's it's super easy now
right so we know the C so the ship gets
easy right um how many from each
decade come on um just quickly asking a
question in the interest of time do you
want me to run uh with the rest of it
[Music]
or
um thank you AI uh do you want me to run
with the rest of the Python pandas
Workshop or uh can I just move on to
spark
I'm going to move on to spark
um
okay let me stop the old
ones right so I'll move on to the spark
notebook and let's cover the first two
really quickly it's the same pattern
we've seen this before right um spark
because it's a Java Library um and the
way spark works is that it it has a
central processing and task scheduling
engine which then delegates the tasks to
individual machines so if you have data
that is larger than the memory of one
machine spark can distribute
it and process chunks in parallel um
it's it's um just like pandas built upon
uh numai and python spark built upon the
basic low lowlevel stuff that Hado
provided right and it it came out of I
think berly uh really successful but
you're now dealing with Java Scala and
python so operationally it's kind of
complicated but let's look at it for for
like 30 seconds
and you'll realize it's super super
simple because we know the C so I'm
using this Library called f spark uh
just to uh get wherever my spark is
installed in my machine and then just
quickly create a
session a lot of people ask me this
question about uh the difference between
a spark session and a spark context it's
kind of in the name right a session is
an entire spark uh cluster running right
and a context is your passport to that
cluster so multiple people can use that
and so the one the one key that's given
to you to access that resource is your
context right so uh I don't know why
it's not creating but hopefully it will
in due
time yeah spark runs slow on my machine
oh here we go we have one all right so
let me uncomment and run this we have
spark uh and Spark gives you the spark
UI uh that I can open in a different tab
hopefully continue to HTT right now I
can see all the jobs that are running
the stages that that uh each job is at
and so on so we'll not cover this bit
let's just get to data munging right
back to our business we have spark
running you have all the scripts do that
super simple
um let's set up the schema for each of
these uh data files right so we've we've
specified the schema before in pandas if
you remember we just have to use the
stru struck Fields construct here uh
believe it or not for functional
programming reasons because we're
running in Java now we do not have the
luxury of duct typing so there you will
see certain OS syncrasy creep up into
the code that you'll have to account for
um but once that's over it's just again
just mechanics
um and we get to load the movie
again there we go so again this how
imagine how this data is getting created
basically a call is going to the Java
virtual machine which is returning this
raw data so you don't have that that
glossy looking
python pandas table here anymore you
basically have a plain text
representation of the data right so it's
a DOT show does the first 10 and so on
so there's this notion of an action in
spark spark is the first one that we're
touching that does lazy evaluation it
still has row oriented data
representation but it's doing Lazy
evaluation it's not going to run your
com computation until you call call one
of these actions and actions are
basically a fancy way of saying show me
the results give me all the results
that's it
right um so we're we're going to just
load different different files here see
if it works and that's it it's working
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
stop this
one and move on to the actual data
analysis one and then I think we'll run
out of time um I wanted to do desk it
was so much fun but you know another
time um and the workshops live on GitHub
it it creeps growing so please connect
there I think you're gonna have a lot of
fun um here we go so now we have a new
spark session I'm going to create a new
one here takes a minute in my machine um
but we in the meantime can oh this one
this time was
awesome I think it knows that I'm
running out of town so this time we're
looking at a beautiful set of problems
here okay we want to be able to clean up
some data then we want to be able to say
list all the unique tags that are found
sorted lexically a before b b before c c
before D and so
on and then which movies have most
number of
tags which users have added most number
of tags which users have added most
number of tag which users have tagged
most numbers movies right so these are
kind of like the the
first um light bulb questions that come
to you when I say hey there's a tags
file and it's got movies and tags in it
right so let's load the data again this
time I've just crunched everything into
a single cell should be
fast um and we have the tags data with
us so I'm going to just try the first
couple of
exercises um in the meantime if you have
any
questions uh I would request that you
start putting them in the chat or in
discussions wherever you like and then
we'll start covering those
up so um again same we're defining some
regular expressions in order to be able
to extract the quotation Mars and um
that's it we're we're basically just
going to
filter uh uh each value and see if we're
able to trap the individual quotes right
um here we go
so first we converted everything into a
lower tag just just so we are able to
better uh compare things um and then we
did a distinct it's it's not that
hard right how do you do a distinct you
either do a group y or you do a distinct
and let's compare both of them right
um so let's I think let's
compare oh let's do this one as well
the distinct tags one was using the word
distinct the compute distinct and then
show was the action that caused the
compute here we're using a group by and
count and shows the action that causes
compute right so let's compare the two
and
um and if we just look at the
explanations for each of these you'll
actually see that they're they're
identical I think I have it here
right so we actually have it here in in
for both distinct and group ey and what
you'll realize is that internally
they're
identical distinct is the same as group
ey effectively we have a dictionary and
we're looking at unique
keys so even in spark which is a
distributed whatever whatever whatever
it's the same thing it's we just need a
dictionary in a bunch of keys right um
and then we can then you know continue
on our way of for for cleaning up all
these uh quot marks right so we
have I think we've covered oh there's
actually
a there's actually a
URL uh with a Christmas in it so good I
think I think we caught it and we know
how many movies have each tag right so
uh Christmas goes to 1100 movies
uh but Christmas England history goes to
one
movie and tree dealer goes to one movie
I don't know I don't know which one this
is interesting um right and so now let's
move on to the next question which is
how many which movies have most number
of tags we have two minutes
awesome
um and we're doing the same thing it's
basically the same groupy that we have
right right and we now see
that that sci-fi has 658 and so on and
so forth right um so we we could like
basically order by
[Music]
um let's do a joint let's let's figure
out what that movie is that has so many
Tex tag right that so many people have
tagged
sci-fi
[Music]
um yeah we saw this movie before right
we saw this one in the
first
notebook yeah this art film art film
went around right um and so on and so
forth so we're I think we're 50% through
um let me just give you the summary uh
notes on
spark um it is lazy
has a has a slightly more complex
ecosystem uh which makes the operations
the deployment of the Clusters the
management of the Clusters data IO
maintenance that becomes a significant
part of their of your strategy of using
spark right a a significant portion of
your cost will actually go there instead
of actual data analysis
um and you know I've described the
details of the eager evaluation versus
lazy evaluation and so on here um but
that's about it right so let me scroll
all the way down thank you P data Global
you folks are all
Aces and I'm open to
questions there's a question when would
you use spark instead of pandas I would
always go with pandas first aam's razor
use a simpler one for first um but
obviously pandas grow slow uh really
really fast right if your if your data
grows I think pandas gets really slow
really fast right so so if if your
computer is really slow or if your um
data is larger than the memory available
in your system prefer spark uh you're
going to have to fight with your it team
to get spark
running that's kind of a cost or if
you're on Amazon Sage maker and and um
glue provide spark managed so there it's
super easy uh both on Amazon and on gcp
and Azure uh it's really easy to pick it
up in cloud but but for physical systems
or data centers you're going to have to
fight with some people right is it
possible we continue with SH I'd like to
listen to him more oh thank you so much
that's like the best comment
ever
yeah I don't know Pi data gonna Pi data
people are going to come to my house and
beat me later so I don't want that does
not getting recorded right it is oh
um thank you Kalan I really was hoping
that you'll join the call so thank you
so much
um Carolina I'm I'm from a computer
science background I do the same thing
thank you
um using pandas and python together
analy is a great starting point but
before settling on just
this I okay yeah so I I don't know if we
have any more
questions I don't know how to close
the meeting um there was somebody else
who was hosting this with me right uh
can I invite them
back I know know GMA thank you so much I
know I I've done this for five days and
I don't get bored it's it's really
interesting when you start looking at
data and uh I have situations where I
then marry the IMDb data with with uh
the movie lens data set and then we look
at the bias built into the ratings or if
there is any built into the ratings and
the risk and so on and so for so we
quantify the movie industry so so uh
this really helped me build the business
case for releasing my film actually so
yeah there's a practical use
here um thank you Mina thank you Liam um
I did I
lose did I lose the
host I'm really stuck what do we do next
this is f should we just continue well
well yeah yeah sorry um sorry I
had yes so you didn't the host yep okay
sorry I I didn't know what to do and so
I'm kind of lost let me stop sharing
guys hey Conrad thank you I panicked for
like 30 seconds I kind of went nuts um
all
right
there thank you Christ I appreciate
the have we all wrapped up because we're
trying to start the next
session right okay so everybody thank
you for joining and then
I wish you all the best connect with me
on the on GitHub or LinkedIn and uh I
look forward to every other session on P
thank you so much